c'est l'heure du journal de l'Afrique
soit il est bienvenus sur France 24 à la
une ce soir le capitaine Moussa Dadis
Camara en prison l'ex dictateur guinéen
et plusieurs c'est quoi accusés ont été
incarcérées à la veille de la tenue de
leur procès ils vont être jugés ce
mercredi pour le massacre comique le 28
septembre 2009 au stade de Conakry
témoignage des victimes et retour sur
cette journée avec notre correspondant à
Conakry
le Nigéria qui doit faire face au pire
inondations en disant le bilan fait état
de 300 morts les pluies ont également
détruit les récoltes aggravant une crise
alimentaire qui touche déjà plusieurs
pays d'Afrique de l'Ouest et à la fin de
ce journal on vous plonge dans l'ancien
royaume de Dahomey dans l'actuel Bénin
c'est de l'histoire de sa reine que
s'est inspirée le nouveau bloc Buster
américain de womanking il retrace
l'épopée extraordinaires des Amazones
notre correspondante au Bénin Emmanuel
Sodji vous raconte leur histoire
reportage à suivre
le capitaine Dadis Camara est dit de ses
coaccusé doivent répondre à partir de ce
mercredi de leur responsabilité présumée
dans le massacre du stade de Conakry le
28 septembre 2009 l'ex dictateur exilé
au Burkina Faso est arrivé ce weekend à
Conakry il s'est présenté devant le
procureur ce mardi a été incarcéré à la
veille de son procès écoutait son avocat
nos clients
ne devaient courir aucun risque jusqu'à
ce que l'audience s'ouvre jusqu'à ce
qu'une décision interviennent à ce stade
ni le procureur de la République ni la
juridique sont de jugement ne pouvait
priver nos clients de leur liberté dès
lors que l'ordonnance c'est-à-dire que
la décision judiciaire qui est résultée
de l'instruction et qui a permis
l'organisation du procès n'indique une
quelconque
privation de liberté d'un procès on peut
pas appeler les accusés leur dire bon
écoutez on vous envoie en prison il n'y
a aucun type de détention mais hélas
nous avons été incompris
voilà il répondait aux questions de
Malik Diakité notre correspondant à
Conakry qui est avec nous ce soir
bonsoir Malik Malik quels ont été les
conditions de l'arrestation de du
capitaine Moussa Dadis Camara
bonsoir
comme vous le voyez nous sommes devant
le tribunal qui va abriter le procès du
28 septembre Moussa délice Camara et 5
autres ils sont arrivés entre 13h et 15h
après 30 minutes avec le procureur avec
les juges d'instruction au sein même du
nouveau tribunal à Moussa Dadis Camara
et les 5 inculpés dans les massacres du
28 Septembre 2009 ont été directement
conduits à la prison centrale de Conakry
et le cortège était très cortège et très
sécurisé Moussa Dadis Camara est arrivé
dans un véhicule tout noir il a suivi le
bus qui a transporté les autres inculpés
jusqu'à la maison centrale de Conakry
Malik il n'a pas été le seul vous le
dites à être arrêté qu'en est-il des
autres accusés justement
exactement Moussa Dadis Camara n'est pas
le seul qui a été arrêté aujourd'hui ils
étaient au nombre de 6 et parmi lesquels
on peut citer Claude Pivi qui a été
lettre de
qui a été à un moment le responsable de
la sécurité présidentielle du de
l'ex-président Alpha Condé et colonel
Quiberon qui est bien connu au Guinée
qui a été le secrétaire général des de
la lutte contre les
la lutte contre les la drogue en Guinée
ce sont les deux les plus connus
aujourd'hui en Guinée ils ont été tous
conduits parce que ils étaient encore en
fonction sous le régime d'Alpha Condé
mais ce soir ils vont passer la première
nuit à la maison centrale de Conakry
merci beaucoup Malik Diakité notre
correspondant à Konakry nous suivons
bien évidemment avec vous ce procès
retrouve régulièrement d'autres victimes
du massacre du 28 septembre dans ce
centre il y a 13 ans elle a subi un viol
par un groupe de militaires en marge de
la manifestation réprimée dans le sang
c'est avec un immense soulagement
qu'elle accueille aujourd'hui
l'ouverture d'un procès
mais c'est quelque chose qui me rend
qui a tout détruit à moi
mais heureusement aujourd'hui je suis là
je témoigne encore avant le jour J les
équipes de la vie pas la principale
association de victimes sont plus
mobilisées que jamais depuis l'annonce
de la tenue du procès des dizaines de
personnes se sont manifestées auprès
d'eux pour témoigner la salle de
secrétariat c'est là qu'on est en train
d'enregistrer les victimes l'association
nourrit beaucoup d'espoir nous voulons
vraiment la vérité nous voulons
qu'il y ait des réparations nous voulons
une reconnaissance nationale pour toutes
les victimes de développement
et nous espérons avoir une justice
claire
transparente pas de parodie de justice
et en présence de tous ceux qui ont été
inculpés dans ce dossier 13 personnes
sont inculpées le plus attendu sur le
banc des accusés c'est le capitaine
Moussa Dadis Camara à la tête de la
jante au pouvoir au moment de la tuerie
ces avocats confirment qu'ils se
présentera bien devant les juges
il est aujourd'hui pressé pour se
présenter devant les ministres en charte
de ce dossier
livrer sa part de vérité et laver son
Honor et son intégrité qui ont été
souhaits pendant 13 ans par ses
accusations fallacieuses qui ne se
repose sur aucun élément probant les
autorités assurent que tout est fin prêt
pour le bon démarrage de ce procès
historique
et puis c'est en ce jour anniversaire
qui amnesty International a choisi de
publier son rapport sur les violences
sexuelles en Guinée l'ONG a réclamé une
meilleure prise en charge des victimes
de viol et l'adoption en urgence d'une
loi générale sur les violences basées
sur le genre
le Burkina Faso toujours la cible des
terroristes islamistes selon l'armée
plusieurs personnes auraient été tuées
lundi dans l'attaque d'un convoi de 150
véhicules transportant des marchandises
vers Djibo une ville du nord du pays des
dizaines de camions ont été détruits
on part à présent au Nigeria le pays
connaît à ses pires inondations en 10
ans le bilan fait état de 300 morts et
100 000 déplacés les pluies ont
également anéanti les récoltes aggravant
une crise alimentaire qui touche déjà
plusieurs pays d'Afrique de l'Ouest
Laurent versent
entre deux orages Kabiru à salam air
dans sa plantation de riz ravagée par
les inondations
de retour au village le jeune
agriculteur profite d'une rare éclaircie
pour sauver ce qu'il reste de sa récolte
les inondations ont apporté du sable qui
a complètement recouvert nos rivières
nous essayons de récolter le peu qu'il
nous reste et les pluies n'ont jamais
été aussi destructrices
depuis plusieurs mois des pluies
torrentiels s'abattent sur une partie de
l'Afrique de l'Ouest provoquant
d'importantes inondations et ravageant
les récoltes au Nigeria l'un des pays
les plus touchés des milliers
d'exploitations agricoles ont été
détruites depuis le début de l'année
menaçant d'aggraver une crise
alimentaire qui sévit dans les régions
les plus pauvres au-delà des pertes
immédiates les inondations ont recouvert
les champs de sable et de bitume rendant
la terre stérile impossible donc de
replanter pour l'instant
désemparés ces agriculteurs lancent un
appel à l'aide
amis nous appelons le gouvernement et
les agences internationales à nous
soutenir
nous demandons à tous ceux qui le
peuvent de faire preuve de compassion et
de nous venir en aide
les inondations ont déjà fait plus de
300 morts et 100000 déplacés dans le
nord du Nigeria depuis le début de
l'année
le roi du Maroc Mohammed VI
officiellement invité au sommet de la
Ligue arabe qui se tiendra en début
novembre à Alger un émissaire du
président algérien abdéma j'étais Bouna
remis mardi à Rabat une lettre
d'invitation au roi la rumeur de la
participation du Maroc au sommet à Alger
a circulé déjà depuis plusieurs jours le
climat entre les deux pays voisins est
très tendus en raison de la question du
Sahara occidental
cette décision des autorités nigériennes
le pays a suspendu le transit des
produits pétroliers destinés au Mali
voisins pour des raisons sécuritaires en
raison de la menace grandissante des
groupes djihadistes les produits
destinés à la mission des Nations Unies
au Mali sont toutefois exemptées de
cette suspension
ce procès sans précédent au Sénégal des
pêcheurs et des associations locales
attaquent en justice une usine de
transformation de poissons pour des
raisons environnementales des usines
souvent accusées par les locaux d'être
responsables de la réfraction pardon de
la ressource et d'une grosse pollution
reportage dailymond Daho
mobilisation exceptionnelle devant la
cour d'appel des caisses on collectif
d'habitants du village de caillards au
nord de Dakar évolue réclamer la
fermeture de l'usine de farine de
poisson TPM x Sénégal cette saison
fonctionne sans respecter les normes
environnementales sans même se conformer
aux recommandations que lui ont permis
d'avenir un agrément frauduleux le
collectif a bien par Greenpeace dénonce
des déversements de déchets à l'odeur
nauséabonde aux abords d'un lac contiguë
au village il fut 10 également une
exploitation abusive des ressources
asiatiques
5 kg de poissons vont servir à fabriquer
un kilo la farine de poisson destinée à
aller nourrir des animaux des animaux de
compagnie des poissons d'élevage dans
les pays développés et le paradoxe c'est
que ce poisson là qui est transformé en
farine pour aller nourrir des animaux
c'est la nourriture de base des
populations sénégalaise en cette période
d'hivernage marquée par la baisse des
débarquements au Quai des pêches de
Gaillard les femmes transformatrices de
poissons sont presque en chômage
technique Mariama dénonce une
concurrence déloyale de l'usine
débarqué on n'arrive plus à travailler
il n'y a plus de poissons
l'entreprise Touba protéine marine
rejette les accusations à son endroit
son PDG dit employer 60 personnes
directement et 300 indirectement selon
lui l'usine respecte toutes les normes
une
usine de parfumerie sans du parfum
usine de viande sans de la viande mais
une usine de poisson sort du poisson
c'est lui qui les poissons il doit avoir
une licence de pêche et des bateaux il y
a aucune usine de farine de poisson au
Sénégal qui a une licence et qui a en
bateau ils veulent pas qu'on se
développe et maintenant il se mêle
derrière des jeunes des chemins 3 ou 4
qui se manipulent pour dire que nous
sommes au canard il n'a rien qu'est-ce
qui a construit Greenpeace le procès qui
oppose les différentes parties et
renvoyées aux 6 octobre
quand l'extraordinaire histoire des
Amazones du Dahomey inspirent un film
américain un gros budget réalisé par
Dina print baytwood avec en tête
d'affiche vaiola Davis the womanking
s'inspire de l'histoire extraordinaire
des Amazones et de sa reine notre
correspondante au Bénin Emmanuel Sodji
s'est rendu à la source dans l'ancien
royaume du Dahomey reportage
dans l'actuel Bénin les vestiges du
d'arôme est plus puissants royaume
d'Afrique de l'Ouest au XVIIIe siècle
ces temps sur près de 48 hectares les
Amazones ont été vaincus par les troupes
coloniales françaises mais leur danse
c'est leur chant de guerre sont restés
intactes depuis 4 siècles
de courage dans les exécutants cette
chorégraphie et ses champs forts est
constituent une meute de in qui sont qui
est assoiffé de sang à l'origine de
cette troupe d'élite appelée à goget en
langue locale c'est la reine
à avoir régné ayant pris le pouvoir par
accident à la mort de son frère jumeau
le roi Akaba elle décide de se travestir
en homme elle crée une garde rapprochée
100% féminine parce qu'elle se méfie des
hommes qui ne concevaient pas sa
présence au pouvoir
la reine elle-même allait à la guerre
même quand elle était enceinte et
aussitôt après avoir accouché les hommes
la méprisés elle n'avaient pas confiance
en eux c'est donc ce régiment de femmes
qu'il a aidé à régner malgré tout son
règne n'a duré que trois ans un de ses
frères la fait abdiquer en tuant son
fils de l'histoire de la première des
Amazones l'actuel représentante en a
hérité cette massue symbole du pouvoir
il reste peu d'objets ayant appartenu
aux Amazones du drahome et la plupart
ayant été emportés par les troupes
coloniales françaises elles ont toutes
une dame comme ça fixée à la ceinture
elles avaient également une arme blanche
qu'on appelait là-dedans
qui est métallique pour égorger les
soldats ennemis cette fabuleuse histoire
des Amazones surpassant les hommes à
tenter d'être effacé ce jour-là Gabin
dit assez est tout heureux d'annoncer à
ce descendant d'Amazon la sortie d'un
film en Occident qui évoque leur
histoire je suis content qu'il y ait un
film car ça fait la promotion de ma
culture de mes origines les femmes se
sont sacrifiées pour la défense de ce
pays mais plus personne n'en parle
aujourd'hui justice est rendue quel que
soit le contenu du film l'essentiel
qu'on en parle longtemps la vie de la
seule femme régnante de l'actuel Bénin a
été
occultée dans les programmes scolaires
désormais les Béninois sont fiers que
l'histoire de la première des Amazones
et de son corps de femme soldat face le
tour du monde
voilà c'est la fin du journal de
l'Afrique merci de nous être fidèles
merci aux équipes en régie merci à notre
chef d'édition Celia carracena merci à
nos correspondances en qui ce journal ne
pourrait pas se faire
[Musique]